COMING TO OUR NEXT GAME-- I
REALLY LOVE THIS GAME.
THIS IS "PHOTOBOMBS: CREEPY OR
CUTE."
THANKS TO INSTAGRAM,
PHOTOBOMBING HAS BECOME AN ART--
A SAD, LIVE-ACTION, TROLL ART,
BUT ART NONETHELESS.
COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
A PICTURE, AND FOR 250 POINTS,
YOU HAVE TO TELL ME IF IT WAS
PHOTOBOMBED BY SOMETHING CREEPY
OR CUTE.
WE'RE GOING TO SQUARE AN IMAGE
IN THE BACKGROUND AND YOU TELL
ME IF THE IMAGE IS CREEPY OUR
CUTE.
THIS COUPLE MAKING OUT.
THEY DON'T THINK ANYONE IS
WHO ON WHAT'S GOING ON.
CREEPY OR CUTE.
>> I'M GOING TO GO CREEPY.
>> LET'S FIND OUT.
YES, CREEPY!
WHERE IS THAT HAND?
AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN SEE
THIS AT HOME, BUT IF YOU LOOK
REALLY FAR IN THE BACK, THERE'S
A GUY WATCHING THAT GUY.
IT'S LAYERED.
>> CHRIS, IF YOU LOOK CLOSER,
THE PELICAN IS WATCHING.
>> THIS IS CREPEY DECEPTION.
>> NEXT ONE.
THIS IS PARIS HILTON IN SOME
MOST LIKELY OTHER HORRIBLE
PERSON AT A CLUB.
ANDI OSHO?
>> THIS HAS GOT TO BE CREEPY.
>> YIT'S IN FACT VERY CREEPY.
WHAT IS THAT!
>> CAN'T TELL IF THAT'S DAVID
SPADER GARY BUSEY.
>> THAT'S AN INTERESTING THEORY.
NEAL BRENNAN?
I THINK SO IT'S ACTUALLY PARIS
HILTON'S SOUL TRYING TO ESCAPE
HER BODY.
>> YES, THAT MAKES MORE SENSE.
>> PLEASE!
SWEET FREEDOM!
NEXT ONE, NEXT ONE.
THIS GIRL IS TAKING A SELFIE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, CREEPY OR
CRUIT IN THE BACKGROUND?
ANDI OSHO?
>> I THINK SOMETHING CUTE IS IN
THE BACKGROUND.
>> I THINK YOU MIGHT BE WRONG.
IT'S PRETTY CREEPY.
WHY IS SHE HOLDING A GUN.
>> I DID NOT SEE THAT COMING.
>> HAVE THEY TRAPPED HER IN THE
SHOWER?
I DON'T KNOW HOW I'M GOING TO
GET OUT OF THIS SHOWER.
>> SHE'S, LIKE COME INTO THE
SAFE HOUSE.
>> THIS IS LIKE A FEMINIST
REMAKE OF "PSYCHO."
SHE'S READY FOR HIM.
WHO'S IN THE SHOWER.
SHE'S GOT GUNS.
>> "PSYCHO" REALLY NEED A
SHOTGUN AND A RED NECK.
THIS LOOKS LIKE A PROM PICTURE.
SHE'S GOT THAT TEENAGE I'M NOT
GOING TO SMILE.
I'M NOT GOING TO SMILE.
I WANT TO LOOK COOL.
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
BACKGROUND.
NEAL BRENNAN?
>> SOMETHING CREEPY.
>> YES, CREEPY.
WHY IS THAT HAPPENING?